[Musique]
la neuvième législature cubaines contre
605 députés choisis dans tous les
secteurs de la société
parmi eux 53 % sont des femmes mais
surtout 86% d'entre eux sont nés après
la révolution
l'âge moyen est de 49 ans c'est donc
effectivement un net changement de
génération au pouvoir
les députés ont prêté serment ils sont
élus les dirigeants de l'assemblée et
c'est la présidente de la commission
électorale qui a annoncé la nomination
que tout le monde attend accompagnement
mauvaise pas de surprise donc
l'ingénieur de 57 ans formé au pouvoir
aux côtés de raul castro depuis 2013 va
lui succéder à la tête du pays
miguel diaz cannes elle suscite beaucoup
d'espoir de changement parmi de nombreux
cubains égal au gallia ces quatre amis
sont réunis dans l'appartement de
mauricio ingénieur nucléaire mis au
chômage à l'abandon de la centrale
construite sous l'ère soviétique
il gagne sa vie en louant des chambres
aux touristes dans son appartement avec
une vue imprenable sur la havane le pays
doit changer il n'a pas le choix dit
mauricio parce que raul castro n'a pas
terminé la plus grande partie des
réformes annoncées il faut un secteur
privé plus fort
son épouse sarah et consultante en
matière d'égalité des genres au travail
elle souhaite une meilleure technologie
nous sommes encore à l'ère du néandertal
dit elle elle est employée de l'état
comme sa jeune amie bien qu'à qui est
psychologue leur salaire net à une
patronne de la paroisse il faut
augmenter le niveau de vie dit elle avec
des salaires plus élevés cuba serait un
paradis enfin eduardo est artiste
peintre
il ne croit pas à des changements
politiques immédiats même s'il souhaite
un dialogue
pour lui c'est clair le futur président
a devant lui des défis énormes et les
attentes sont grandes
le professeur esteban morales est
économiste
les réponses des économistes nous disons
que les réformes doivent s'accélérer
qu'il faudrait adopter des mesures un
peu plus audacieuses esteban morales a
été exclu du parti communiste lorsqu'il
a dénoncé la corruption des dirigeants
cubains en 2010 il a été réintégré par
raul castro lui-même qui lui a donné
raison
il croit dias cannelle capable de
terminer les réformes au niveau où nous
avons la même belle seulement dit il il
ne pourra pas le faire tout seul
il y aura comme pour raul castro des
résistances la nomination de miguel diaz
cannelle et du conseil d'état au complet
doit encore être entériné par un vote de
l'assemblée nationale
ce n'est qu'une formalité mais ce qu'on
attend avec beaucoup de curiosité
c'est son premier discours de président
demain jean michel leprince radio canada
à laval